PATRICK: Outer space is a great realm of
possibility and the question is whether or not
that realm of possibility will be closed off.
THOMPSON: We track twenty-five thousand plus
objects continuously to understand where they
are and if they pose a hazard to each other.
PATRICK: There’s a real danger that there’s
going to be militarization of outer space.
BOLDEN: They’ve got to be able to go in and say,
look, I’ve got everything in my arsenal to just
wipe you out. But I don’t want to do
that. I don’t want to make this domain
unusable for everybody.
SIERRA:
Space is an infinite horizon - an endless void
full of possibility. But the part of space near
Earth is getting really crowded. And it’s getting
really dangerous. It used to be just Russia and
the United States, but now nine countries,
and dozens of private entities, are regularly
launching objects into space. All of these players
are competing for limited real estate. Crowding
leads to conflict. And so far the world hasn’t
developed rules to solve space disputes,
or to prevent war from spilling over into the
night sky. As things heat up, some countries
are pouring billions of dollars into space
defense. The technologies are futuristic-sounding,
anti-satellite lasers high-altitude EMP
weapons. But the biggest danger is something
slightly less glamorous ... space junk. I’m
Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It Matters.
Today, will the world ruin space?
PATRICK:
Space junk, some of it’s like the pieces of
defunct satellites, including those that have been
destroyed by anti-satellite weapons tests.
SIERRA: This is Stewart Patrick. He’s a senior
fellow for Global Governance here at
the Council. That means he spends most
of his time trying to figure out how
to get the world to work together.
PATRICK: But basically, there are these pieces of
space junk and they’re hurtling around at almost
twenty thousand miles an hour in low-Earth orbit.
And I don’t know if you saw the movie Gravity, but
what happens is that if those things collide with
a functioning satellite or, say, a space station,
the results could be absolutely catastrophic.
SIERRA: Just rocket Sandra
Bullock out into space.
PATRICK: Exactly. Totally. Yes.
And there are also seven hundred and fifty
thousand pieces that are being tracked that are
larger than a pea but smaller than a softball. So
any one of those could cause catastrophic damage.
And so the question is, how do we deal with all
this space junk? Because if there’s if there’s too
much of an accumulation of space junk, it could
render this outer space domain almost unusable.
SIERRA: Time for a quick zero gravity simulation.
So imagine that every time you threw away an apple
core, or tossed your bag on the couch, it didn’t
land. Instead it just stayed in motion alongside
you. Eventually you’d be surrounded by stuff.
And that would make getting around pretty hard.
That’s basically what happens in space. Everything
stays at the orbit it’s in, moving at the same
speed, until something else touches it. And
there’s so much of it out there that getting into
and around space is dangerous.
SIERRA:
So I’ve heard that Space Command provides a
type of space junk air traffic control.
THOMPSON: That’s correct.
SIERRA: This is Lt General
David Thompson. He’s the Vice Commander of
Air Force Space Command. He helps oversee
the use of space by the U.S. military.
THOMPSON: We operate a global set of sensors.
We track twenty-five thousand plus objects
continuously to understand where they are
and if they pose a hazard to each other. And
if they pose a hazard, we specifically provide
warning to anybody. It might be NASA, it might be
a commercial operator, it might be the Russians
or the Chinese. We provide warning if that’s
a hazard. We do it because today we’re really
the only folks in the world that can do it.
SIERRA: I mean, because an object the size of
your fist moving that quickly could be incredibly
destructive to anything, including a satellite.
THOMPSON: Correct. Absolutely. In fact, objects
a whole lot smaller than that at that speed
create incredible danger. There’s a story—actually
a true story of the space shuttle back when it
was flying in its early days in the 1990s. It had
multi-paned windows, a fleck of paint traveling at
seventeen thousand miles an hour went through
all but the last pane of that window.
SIERRA: A fleck of paint?
THOMPSON: A fleck of paint.
SIERRA: Wow.
THOMPSON: Had it
penetrated that last window
pane, then the atmosphere,
right—the air inside the shuttle would have been
evacuated and they would have had a huge problem.
SIERRA: So, where does space junk come from?
Some of it is created when satellites go dead,
or malfunction, or break up. This is sort
of inevitable and out of our control.
But the other way space junk is created is
more intentional. Since the 1960s,the US and
Russia have been testing their ability to destroy
satellites in orbit. And recently, other countries
have been doing the same. In 2007, for example,
China shocked the world by destroying one of
their own weather satellites with a missile.
RUPPERSBERGER: I’m very concerned that China
has conducted a destructive anti satellite
test against its own satellite, that the
redfield as a result of this was troubling
to our satellites and our space missions.
Patrick MURPHY:India held an anti-satellite
test, now this test created a cloud of
orbital debris, thats flying in low earth orbit
Jim BRIDENSTINE: That is a terrible terrible thing
to create an event that sends debris in an
apogee that goes above the intl space station
that kind of activity is not compatible
with the future of human space flight that
we need to see have happen.
SIERRA: Why would it matter
if someone shot down their own satellite?
THOMPSON: The problem is debris. That 2007 test
that the Chinese executed created more than 3,500
pieces of debris. Ninety percent of that debris is
still in orbit today and poses a threat to all
other satellites operating in that regime.
SIERRA: So if people keep
doing these sorts of tests,
that number will just keep going up and up?
THOMPSON: Correct. Correct. That number will grow.
Those satellites in lower orbits—eventually
that debris will reenter the atmosphere,
but most of the operating location of the
satellites that would be under threat—you know,
we are talking about decades and perhaps centuries
that the debris would remain in orbit.
SIERRA: When you look up at the night sky and
see a satellite blinking by, it’s probably in
something called low earth orbit. This refers to
the first 1,200 miles of space above the earth’s
surface. Some specialized satellites orbit
higher than that, but the majority stay pretty
close to Earth. Theorists worry that conflict
in space, or a cascade of satellite collisions,
could turn low earth orbit into a deadly
traffic jam of debris. If that happened
there’d be no way to get through the junk and
into outer space. That means no new satellites,
no trips to the moon, no Mars missions. And
the problem could last for hundreds of years.
SIERRA: Is the idea to just sort of
flex a muscle and show that you can
shoot down a satellite if you want to?
THOMPSON: They used it as a target just to
demonstrate the capability. Because space is
such an important part of military operations,
it provides tremendous advantages to the armed
forces of the United States and would to anybody.
And so naturally, someone who anticipates they
may end up in a conflict with the United States,
they may think the first thing they need to do in
a war is remove those space capabilities so that
it impacts the U.S.’ ability to
operate. So there is military advantage
to denying use of space to
an adversary in conflict.
SIERRA: So what would the U.S. military look
like without satellites.
THOMPSON: The U.S. military
would look like the military we had in the
twentieth century, industrial age warfare.
As a couple of examples, at the end of World
War II we had a tremendous strategic Air Force.
That Air Force put a thousand airplanes in the
air over Europe, over Germany every single day
at the end of the war, dropped anywhere from
six (thousand) to twelve thousand bombs, all
aimed at one point. But at the end of the—at the
end of the war the U.S. Strategic Bombing Survey
said, of those nine (thousand) to twelve thousand
bombs, only one hundred fell within a half mile
of the target. That’s industrial age warfare. In
Vietnam, there was a strategic railroad crossing
of a river in North Vietnam, took thirty airplanes
and 176 bombs to destroy one railroad bridge.
SIERRA: And Now?
THOMPSON: Now we’re talking about two bombers,
108 bombs, 108 different targets.
SIERRA: Without satellites,
U.S. military operations might look like
something you’d see on the History Channel.
And that’s because satellites are part of nearly
everything the modern military does. It’s not hard
to see why an ambitious enemy would want to gain
the ability to shoot them down, despite the risk
that space junk poses to everyone on the planet.
THOMPSON: Satellite communications allow us to
communicate anywhere on the globe at any time.
Whether you are in the middle of an ocean,
in the middle of a desert, in air space anywhere
in the world. We certainly use satellites to
collect intelligence information from space, and
do that all over the world all the time. And then,
also, things like missile warning. It’s
also a matter of not creating undue damage
on civilian populations, not striking targets
you are not aiming at which would have
undue effect on civilian populations, civilian
infrastructure, and things like that.
SIERRA:This all may seem pretty removed from our
daily lives. But a lot of what satellites do for
the military, they do for the rest of us too. And
our world has become deeply dependent on them.
BOLDEN: One of the things we love to do, and
we’ve never been able to do it worldwide, is get
people to join us in a day without space.
SIERRA: This is Charles Bolden. He ran NASA
under the Obama administration.
Before that he was a marine,
a navy test pilot, and an astronaut.
BOLDEN: So shut down your cell phone,
turn off your television, turn off the
radio in the car, don’t look at your clock,
don’t go to the ATM machine, don’t do anything
that requires precise timing, because it’s gone.
That’s a day without space.
THOMPSON: Most citizens don’t realize just
how important satellites are to them every day.
Let me give you an example, and we’ll talk about
GPS. First of all, the clear and easy answer for
why GPS is so important is the blue dot on your
smartphone, right? You know, navigating around
wherever you are going, following the blue dot,
that’s powered by GPS. It tells you not
only where you are but where you are going.
The second piece of that, though, is GPS just
doesn’t provide positions and navigation,
it also provides timing.
SIERRA: Besides guiding you to
the closest Starbucks or Dunkin Donuts, GPS
is the basis for all kinds of technologies.
It powers financial transactions, cell
phone calls, and emergency medical services.
Amazon uses it to track deliveries. The list
goes on and on. Not many people realize it,
but GPS is provided as a free service to the
world by the United States government.
SIERRA: So satellites go
down, and we lose our GPS.
THOMPSON: Correct.
SIERRA: We lose our weather prediction,
and we lose our streaming Netflix.
THOMPSON: Right.
SIERRA: Not good stuff.
THOMPSON: What is there left to
do? That’s right.
SIERRA:
Netflix aside, let’s be clear. A widespread
satellite failure could be catastrophic.
So many different systems depend on satellites
that nobody has a full picture of what the fallout
might look like. Planes could be grounded.
You could have a hard time taking out money.
The power grid could fail, and the
stock market might be shut down.
Sure, space junk is circling a thousand
miles above our heads, but the problems it
might cause are very much down here on Earth.
Patrick: I think that outer space is a great realm
of possibility. And the question is whether or not
that realm of possibility will be closed off the
route to it will be closed off by the fact that
we can’t overcome our disagreements on Earth.
PATRICK: What we’re seeing in space is a real
democratization, which used to only be limited
to a few big countries that had space programs.
But now you’re seeing the rise of all sorts of
what they call spacefaring nations, like India,
for instance, has emerged as a pretty big player.
But at the same time you’ve got all these private
actors, too. So you’ve got SpaceX by Elon Musk,
and then you’ve got Amazon also has a space
program, and some Chinese equivalents as well.
And these private-sector actors are
putting up huge numbers of satellites,
entire constellations that could have more
than a thousand satellites in each of them.
SIERRA: So it’s just literally getting crowded.
PATRICK: It’s getting really crowded. So part of
that issue is that there’s just no space,
there’s no room to necessarily manage all
of this congestion up there. So the question is,
how do you actually accommodate all these actors
in this new space rush that’s going on?
SIERRA: So is the idea that we need some sort
of traffic cop to lead us around?
PATRICK: Well, one of the big problems
is that there is no real modern set of
rules for a lot of things in outer space.
The granddaddy of all the treaties when it
comes to how to regulate outer space is the
Outer Space Treaty, which is getting pretty long
in the tooth. It’s fifty-two years old now. In
1967 it came into play. The problem with the Outer
Space Treaty is it doesn’t deal with a number of
things that have come to the forefront.
SIERRA: The Outer Space Treaty was built
to deal with cold war concerns. It prevents
countries from claiming Mars as their own,
or placing nuclear launch sites on the moon. But
the people who made it were not thinking about
space junk, or the possibility that Jeff Bezos
would one day be launching thousands of private
satellites. Space has changed since 1967. And this
has left experts thinking about new rules.
PATRICK: I think one of the answers is that you
need to have as much transparency as possible
and you need to have as much ability to monitor
whether or not people are living up to their
commitments. And I think that that’s been one of
the most difficult things in outer space generally
because, obviously, it’s a domain that’s far away
and it’s not easily observable as to how countries
are behaving. There probably is going to
need to be some sort of intergovernmental
organization that actually would be able to
go in and verify whether or not commitments
are actually being made. And that that will
require a level of intrusiveness that is not only
going to bother potential adversaries of
ours, because we get to look at their stuff
and they get to look at our stuff, but a lot of
sovereignty-minded leaders and politicians and
officials in the United States will resist that
because they may not be willing to trade off
that level of transparency, which they think might
give up, you know, some of the state secrets,
in the interest of creating a stable outer-space
realm. But it’s only going to get more and more
competitive and contested if we don’t have some
rules of the road for outer space. It will become
the Wild West, in effect, in outer space.
SIERRA: And the benefits are no joke,
serious science gets done in space. For example,
most of our understanding of climate change
comes from satellites. At any given time,
researchers are conducting scientific and
medical experiments in space that couldn’t
be done anywhere else. Plus, cooperation
in space has helped the U.S. form important
ties. Even with countries that have a tense
relationship with the U.S. down on Earth.
SIERRA: How closely do NASA scientists work with
scientists from other countries?
BOLDEN: NASA scientists and scientists
from other countries try to the greatest
extent to work incredibly closely. When I was
the NASA administrator under President Obama, he
literally charged NASA to, the way he phrased it,
expand the number of nontraditional partners that
you have across the NASA portfolio. And so, you
picked a great example when you mentioned the U.S.
and China. In my role as the NASA administrator,
my job was to do everything in my power to
find a way to enable our countries to work
collaboratively on peaceful things, hoping
that if we could do that then it would delay
if not prevent conflict. I tell people all
the time, I think next to the Department of
State and the Department of Defense NASA is the
greatest provider of soft power for the U.S.,
you know, in our arsenal. So we really work as
hard as we can to try to facilitate peaceful
collaboration among nations. If you look at
the relationship between NASA and Roscosmos,
the Russian space agency, it is a perfect
example of the way that NASA uses its soft
power to try to eliminate the tensions or ease the
tension that comes about almost daily with Russia
in terms of diplomatic relationship. China,
same thing, we work with China in lunar science,
study of the moon. And we work with them in
geodetics, which is the study of earthquakes.
They’re really, really good at it. And so
we try to learn from them, and we try to
use their data and they use our data.
SIERRA: But as things heat up in space,
it’s feeling less and less like a place for
peaceful cooperation. And if things worsen,
these scientific bonds could break.
Patrick: One of the big trends,
and a worrisome trend, is the fact that other
countries are following the U.S. lead in terms of
creating space forces as part of their military
establishment. Recently the French government
has announced that it is also going to
create a space force. There are similar
military doctrines and military instruments
being developed in China, in Russia. I would
not be too surprised to see the Indians follow
suit. It sort of reminds me of the early
nuclear age, where there’s a pell-mell desire
to sort of create one’s own capabilities.
How can we take advantage of this to make
sure that we are not threatened by others? But
by building up those capabilities, then of course
you, by definition, make others insecure. And so
you often get these arms races as a result.
SIERRA: Do you think if we dialed it back they
would too?
PATRICK:
You know, a lot of skeptics
of my arguments would say no.
I think that number of folks self-styled
realists would say, if it’s not going
to be us, it’s going to be somebody else.
BOLDEN: It goes back to the trust but verify.
I’m not sure that we have a way yet to verify that
hostile nations, quote/unquote “hostile” nations
or nations that we’re not exactly sure we
trust in everything, I’m not sure that we
have a way yet to verify that they’re going to
comply with the convention. And so we say, OK,
we just don’t want to do it at all. But people in
the national security apparatus have got to become
much better negotiators and, you know,
consensus-builders than they’ve ever been before.
They’ve got to be able to go in and say, look,
I’ve got everything in my arsenal to just wipe you
out. But I don’t want to do that. And I don’t want
to make this domain unusable for everybody. So
don’t make me do that. Let’s reach some agreement
as to what we’ll use and what the ground rules are
for its use, and what can we take out of the game?
I see more Star Trek than Star Wars. That’s what I
think people always ask, what’s your favorite,
Star Trek or Star Wars, because we have been
conditioned to view Star Trek as scientists and
explorers seeking after good, and Star Wars being
people who are in constant war fighting, yeah.
SIERRA: So we want it to stay Star
Trek and stay away from Star Wars.
BOLDEN: We want it to stay Star Trek and
stay away from Star Wars. Every once in a while,
you know, it’s necessary to put the shields up,
but we shouldn’t put the shields
up just because there’s somebody
else out there who doesn’t look like us.
SIERRA: Space is so essential to our daily lives,
and to our security, that it seems like we
have no choice but to do whatever is necessary
to protect it. But the rush to protect
something can itself lead to conflict.
Humankind has not, as of yet, exported war to
the cosmos. The thing about space is that we
won’t get many chances to get it right - whatever
damage we do could circle the earth for centuries.
The shields may already be up, but
there is still time to figure out
what sort of place we want space to be.
SIERRA: What did you feel the first time
you went to space and looked back on Earth?
BOLDEN: I don’t have a good word because it’s
an overused word, and that’s “awed.” Just
looking at this planet from that vantage
point is awe-inspiring. You saw was the
thin blue line that is our atmosphere.
You saw the ocean. And I always say it’s
one ocean. No borders, no boundaries.
You get the understanding about humanity and
you become sort of an environmentalist. Not
a pacifist, that’s not the right word;
you become someone who is an idealist.
You dream of the world the way it
should be as opposed to, you know,
the way it is.
SIERRA:
Want to learn more about interesting
space things? We got a page for that!
It’s on CFR.org, and it includes things like
show notes, a transcript, and links to a
bunch of really great articles and resources.
Subscribe to Why It Matters on Apple Podcasts,
Spotify, Stitcher or wherever you get your audio.
Be sure to leave us a review, give us some stars,
and please talk about us to your friends!
We want to hear from you directly too, so
holler at us. Our email is whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council on
Foreign Relations. The show is created and
produced by Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross,
and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is
Markus Zakaria. Robert McMahon is our Managing
Editor, and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital
Officer. Our researcher is Rafaela Siewert.
Original music was composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle
Sierra, signing off. See you next time!